[Music]
just as
little is the persistence of the
universal consciousness in its judgment
and unmasking an abolition of hypocrisy
in denouncing hypocrisy as base vile and
so on
it is appealing in such judgment to its
own law just as the evil consciousness
appeals to
its law for the former comes forward in
opposition to the latter and thereby is
a
particular law it has therefore no
superiority
over the other law rather it legitimizes
it
and this zeal does the very opposite of
what it means to do
for it shows that what it calls true or
genuine duty
and which ought to be universally
acknowledged is something not
acknowledged in doing so it concedes to
the other and equal right to be
for itself
paragraph 663 is a relatively short one
and it would be tempting as we want to
get to the end of the morality section
which now we can
see on the horizon to move past it
pretty quickly and say yeah okay i see
what you're saying here this is
balancing this is balancing that
now let's let's move on to the next
developments
but really we should pause and linger
and look closely
at what what hegel is saying here and
also what he doesn't say
here what he leaves for us to sort of
unpack and and open up through our own
questioning so to begin with he
uses the same terminology
about persistence
you know sort of remaining in
a attitude or state insisting
over and over again upon something and
the insistence in this case
is a judgment made by the universal
consciousness so now it's the universal
consciousness
that is persisting it's no longer the
evil
singular acting consciousness who
is you know insisting on doing its own
thing now
now there's two sides to this right
so he tells us just as
little is the persistence of the
universal consciousness
in its judgment so that that's the mode
of
how it is as he's going to say a few
paragraphs later
how it's acting now judgment and action
not exactly the same thing right action
is is doing something
i can judge that it would be good for me
to
write these these things on the
chalkboard or to walk across the room
or to create a video actually doing that
is something quite different i have to
commit myself
and as we're going to see looking ahead
a little bit and also thinking a little
bit behind to the
you know the the beautiful soul what
makes a beautiful soul a beautiful soul
the fact that it doesn't do anything it
just judges
it it passes judgment it also
says something about itself that it's so
good because it's
it's doing the right thing but it's not
doing
anything other than you could say
communicating and cognizing
and perhaps even we might say it works
in the domain of affectivity or the will
as well so just as little as the
persistence of the universal
consciousness and its judgment
and unmasking and abolition
of we can also say undoing
as well of the hypocrisy that it has
been
saying is there in the individual evil
consciousness right so this is a this is
a hypocrite
and we have to denounce hypocrisy we
have to pass
a judgment rutile right we have to take
our part you might say if we want to
play off the
tile part of the term
and we want to strip off the mask we
want to
thereby undo the hypocrisy we want to
get the hypocrite
the evil consciousness to say oh yeah
i've been wrong
i shouldn't have done that and and
instead the evil consciousness persisted
and so what we've got here
basically is two consciousnesses saying
it is
it isn't it is it isn't going back and
forth
like cartoon characters right
so uh he goes on and he says in
denouncing
hypocrisy as base vile
and so on um right so the
and so on is is basically etc
um these are not the only things that
the hypocrite could be called
we might come up with all sorts of other
examples so base
schlect right the the lower
consciousness the um person who's
actually
going back to the earlier dialectics you
know we oppose this to the noble
consciousness
vile neither trek right bringing things
down to the lower
level tearing things down right so
hypocrisy is is bad it's a bad thing we
don't want to
be that or do that he says and so we're
judging as the universal consciousness
that that's the case
he says in doing this and denouncing
hypocrisy
it is appealing in such judgment to a
to a law to a gazettes
so we can call this law we can call this
norm we could call it normativity
whatever we want here but
is this law like in capital letters
for everybody all at the same time
and this this evil consciousness over
here
is holding itself stubbornly
hippocratically however we want to put
it
vilely against the law that everybody
recognizes
well that's the way universal
consciousness is spinning it at first
but thou universal consciousness gets to
see
that it's really its own law
it's it's not a law for everybody in
fact it's coming from universal
consciousness
just as much as the law or or norm or
whatever we're going to say that the
individual
is following is coming from itself and
so
it's not really for universal
consciousness a universal
law and study says um
it's appealing in such judgment to its
own law just as the evil consciousness
appeals to
its law so now we have two laws
as the former that is universal
consciousness
comes forward in opposition to the
latter
and thereby as a particular
law so we have now two
particular laws two particular
let's call them ways of of arranging
things of valuing things of
deciding what principles count and what
principles don't
two particular ways confronting each
other how do we choose between them
you know you know the universal
consciousness has been saying my law
is the law but
now it undergoes a sort of crisis of uh
confidence you might say so he says it
has therefore no superiority
over the other law rather now here's one
of the places where we should ask a
question rather
it legitimizes it
and here the the term that hegel is
using
is actually you know in german
they get to medzirin right so it's it's
transliterating it to call it
legitimizes it
it gives it legitimacy what does that
mean here
and why why would it legitimize it
rather than
say nullifying both laws at the same
time hegel doesn't tell us
unless the clue is in what what follows
so he says this zeal does the very
opposite of what it means to do
so what's zeal the zeal on the part of
universal consciousness
to denounce hypocrisy it does the exact
opposite of denouncing hypocrisy
and thereby instead legitimizes
the law the norm the way of operating
that the individual
evil consciousness has worked out for
itself
and what does that mean now does that
mean that everything becomes
hypocrisy everything becomes base vile
just as much on this side so hegel said
that this legitimizes
it instead of just simply tearing it
down
the next thing that he says is is
on its surface puzzling at least when we
read it
so again we have to be very careful
readers of the text he says
the zeal does the very opposite of what
it means to do why
four it shows what it calls true
or genuine duty now
here miller is actually you know true
and genuine
both just var right true
so he didn't have to add in the extra
thing true and genuine duty
var flicked um true and genuine duty
what it's calling that what it's naming
as that and which ought to be
universally
acknowledged right so there's there's
already some other moral terminology
here
zol and zolin is a modal verb
in in german and it denotes sometimes
well that that's the sort of thing that
should happen
what we expect in this case it's saying
this is a a moral requirement this
should be acknowledged this uh true and
genuine duty
ought to be acknowledged universally
and acknowledged now isn't that an
interesting
expression to use at this point
acknowledge uh recognition
right on air cannon something that we've
been looking for
through the entire phenomenology
recognized as such in the
self-consciousness section
worked out in greater and greater detail
in the
reason and spirit section which we're
approaching the end of
now can recognition be given to
duty or is duty being treated
almost in a personal way at that point
as if it has
more than just something to be you know
recognized and unfollowed but something
to be
obeyed something to be uh treated as
having an
agency of its own well you know in this
section duty is within us
so i think that's that's something that
we could we could say right
and we've had a number of points in this
uh subsection
where you know the person or the
community is
in fact um what is looking to be
recognized and providing recognition so
it should be
acknowledged and then hegel says
it's something not acknowledged and
it's displayed as so right
something not acknowledged displayed
as nicked on a contest and you could
translate that as something that's not
acknowledged or you could translate it
as
the not acknowledged right and
so this is this is quite interesting
here we're going to come back to this in
a moment
he says in doing so it concedes what's
the it
universal consciousness to the other an
equal right to be
for itself an equal right to forza zein
not just an equal right to be for itself
an equal right of
being for itself of calling its own
shots
of judging itself
it doesn't just have to accept the
judgment coming from the universal
consciousness
now i do want to come back to this for a
moment this is something hegel is not
saying here but this is
this reminds me of something that comes
up in ethic class after ethics class
after ethics class whenever i teach it
there's always some people who and they
hear about some sort of
universal norms
and it could be utilitarian it could be
deontological it could be virtue ethics
it could be whatever you want
they're always like but people break the
rules
so the rules can't really be rules can
they
they're they're mixing up like universal
law
they say of gravity with universal laws
that would apply to human beings
and this is part of what's peculiar not
just to ethics but to human beings we
can make
norms for ourself and we can break those
norms
it really depends on recognition of
those norms
doesn't it and of our duties or of you
know whatever else we're going to
frame it as whatever principles we're
going to use
this is not i think a defect within
ethics i think this is part of
what makes ethics ethics and so i'm
going to leave that pregnant phrase
out there that doesn't actually tie in
so much with the movement going here but
it's an interesting side note to pick up
on
this judgment has however at the same
time another aspect from which it
becomes the way to a resolution of the
antithesis confronting it
the consciousness of the universal in
its relation to the first evil
consciousness
does not behave as one that is actual
and acts for the latter is rather the
actual consciousness but in its
antithesis to it it is a consciousness
that is not entangled in the antithesis
of individuality
and universality which occurs when
action is entered upon
it remains in the universality of
thought behaves as a consciousness that
apprehends
and its first action is merely one of
judgment
now through this judgment it places
itself as we have just remarked
alongside the first consciousness and
the latter
through this likeness comes to see its
own self in this other consciousness
for the consciousness of duty maintains
an attitude of passive apprehension
but it is thereby in contradiction with
itself as the absolute will of duty as a
consciousness whose determining
comes solely from itself it does well to
preserve itself and its purity
for it does not act it is the hypocrisy
which wants its judgment to be taken for
an actual
deed and instead of proving its
rectitude by actions
does so by uttering fine sentiments
its nature then is altogether the same
as that which is reproached with making
duty a mere matter of words
in both alike the side of reality is
distinct from the words uttered in the
one
through the selfish purpose of the
action in the other through the failure
to act at
all although the necessity to act is
involved in the very talk of duty for
duty without without deeds
is utterly meaningless
paragraph 664 begins in a rather
promising way he says this judgment
has however at the same time another
aspect
from which it becomes the way to a
resolution of the
antithesis confronting it and when we
get to the end of the paragraph
we'll we'll see that this is not as much
of a
resolution and out losing as
we had hoped for i do want to point out
though before we jump into this
so you know miller has a tendency to
translate
using the term antithesis in ways that
could be a little bit
confusing contradiction would be another
way of of talking about this here
or even opposition gagen zots uh
for hondon and gagenzotz the the
contradiction or the antithesis that is
presenting itself that is ready
at hand that is there to be seen
for these shapes of consciousness that
are are confronting each other
both concerned with conscience
and with with duty and so looking at
this judgment this urtile that's being
made on the part of universal
consciousness
which here he talks about is
consciousness of the universal we're
going to come back to that in a moment
as well
is going to help us to resolve these
these
oppositions and this is a paragraph
that's
full of terminology of opposition
uh another term that's being translated
as
antithesis and and gag and gazettes
being set
over against something else there's also
wiedersbrook
in here as as well and then there's
the the contradiction between
universality and individuality which
is also called an antithesis so there's
a lot of being conscious of things being
set against each other being opposed to
each other and the question is how are
these going to
move how are these going to shift what
sort of
transformation of consciousness are we
going to have here so
he says the consciousness of the
universal
now why doesn't he just say the
universal consciousness
as he's been you know doing in the
paragraphs previously or
just even just the universal that's all
good minor right the consciousness
of the universal should we read in there
that there's
a shift taking place here that the
universal
is no longer just a consciousness
and rather now there is starting to be a
slide
where the consciousness that's been
viewing itself as universal is now
realizing it's not quite as universal
that would be set up by the previous
paragraph would it not
so i think that that's arguably a good
way to read
this shift in language he goes on and he
says
the consciousness of the universal in
its relationship to the first
evil consciousness does not behave as
one
that is actual it's not veer clique
right
and acts it doesn't engage in conduct
handling not just individual action but
like
courses of action why
because the latter is rather the actual
consciousness the
the first evil particular consciousness
which now we've seen has a law of its
own right that is one that that that in
fact does
act that behaves that that risks that
goes out
into the world and so he goes on and he
says
the latter is the actual consciousness
but
in its antithesis to it so how it's
being set against how it's setting
itself against it
is a consciousness that is not entangled
in
what is happening over here on the part
of the acting consciousness the
individual consciousness
being entangled in the antithesis of
individuality
and universality which occurs he says
when action handled again here
is entered upon so you know if you're
going to
do something if you're actually going to
try to follow duty
if you're going to make some sort of
effort to change the world even to
change oneself
that goes beyond making judgments
cognizing
talking when you're engaging the will
which is the faculty that does affect
the world
then you get engaged in what we saw
earlier in this this section this this
antithesis between universality
individuality just to like skip ahead a
little bit
what is the individuality problematic
side well selfishness being
self-centered
here and being taking cues from one's
natural
being and that natural being includes
you know the
what kant called the inclinations and
desires that you have as a
being that has a body and is acting in
certain ways and has been shaped by
experiences and psychological laws has
certain propensities
but it it you could say that it also
includes
um other aspects as well not just this
you know being being a natural thing a
very
complex natural thing but also
this you know it's motivated as equally
by by a certain desire for recognition
that's part of our nature
so um coming back to this right we've
got this this distinction here now
that's not happening on the side of the
consciousness
of the universal so he's what is
happening he says
it remains in the universality of
of thought so it's not the universality
of community it's not the universality
of language it's not the universality
of duty in action it's the universality
of just
thinking and it can involve those of
course right that can
happen through a community through
communication right
but it's it's not doing anything so
he goes on and he says here we go
um universality thought behaves as a
consciousness that apprehends
now behaves there is not a form of
acting apprehending
alphos right it's describing how this
thing is it's
grasping itself it's grasping this
antithesis it's grasping
what's going on i'm going to be unhappy
about that in just a moment
and its first action he says is merely
one
of judgment judgment is not yet acting
now is it it's saying things about stuff
but
anybody can judge actually doing things
i mean we should pause on this for a
minute think about this
we live in a universe saturated by
traditional media that is morphed in
very interesting ways and social media
and most of the time people are
blathering and making judgments about
stuff very often without
any any real insight into what they're
judging about
many people take that as having engaged
in
action so you know posting pictures of
homeless people and saying the
government should be doing something
about that
that's a judgment actually getting
yourself out there
and taking food to you know or you know
hand warmers or whatever it's going to
be
to people in 10 cities that's action
those are two
very different domains now judgment can
lead to action
but judgment by itself isn't action
and can often become a substitute for
action
can't it that's what's happening on the
part
of the universal in relation to the evil
consciousness the singular consciousness
so he says
through this judgment it places itself
as we've just remarked
alongside neban the first consciousness
and the latter through this likeness
comes to see its own self in the other
consciousness
now he says for the consciousness of
duty maintains an attitude of passive
apprehension but it is thereby in
contradiction
with itself as the absolute
will of duty as a consciousness
whose determining comes solely from
itself
so this is an interesting phrase the
absolute will of duty
duty if it's taken seriously taken as
seriously as it should be
would lead to willing would lead to
a faculty not only of choosing but of
deciding
of committing oneself of doing something
the will leads to action so we have a
contradiction here a vitas rook
a contradiction within itself on whose
side
on the side of the consciousness of the
universal
how so he said well he goes on and he
says
it does well to preserve itself in its
purity for it does not
act and now notice who's the hypocrite
here man
right it's not just the one who's
accused of hypocrisy by the universal
consciousness
the hypocrisy is on both sides
okay common realization right the world
is is a flawed one and anybody can be
be viewed as a hypocrite in this case
though there is a hypocrisy
condemning the other for hypocrisy when
it's a hypocrite itself it's sort of
like
you know meta hypocrisy in this case he
says
it is the hypocrisy which wants its
judging
to be taken for an actual deed and
instead of proving its rectitude by
actions
does so by uttering fine sentiments
this is the person who condemns what the
government is doing but doesn't do a
thing about it other than you know
signing petitions
and posting things on facebook or
twitter
or instagram or what what have you this
is the lover
who professes love but doesn't actually
do any
actions involved in in
you know externalizing that that emotion
that
that act of willing this is the person
who claims that they care for
others under their charge but actually
exploits them
or doesn't do anything to prevent their
exploitation by other we could
multiply example after example after
example
right and so that's what's happening on
the side of the universal
it is a hypocrisy that wants judging to
be taken for an
actual deed so he says its nature
therefore is altogether the same
as that which is reproach which making
duty a mere matter of words what is this
the beautiful soul
right that we we saw before now in both
alike he says the site of reality is
distinct from the words uttered
in the one now who's both alike
we come back to the singular
consciousness
the consciousness of the universal
they're both hypocrites
in some way right the the singular
because
of its own selfishness it it says that
it's trying to fulfill duty
but it really just wants to do what it
wants to do because it's good for it
it's satisfying the demands or desires
or drives of its natural being
and then masking that with you know
saying i'm doing the right thing but
this over here
is in some respect more contemptible
it doesn't do anything it just talks
talks talks talks talks
it comes up with you know spreadsheets
and plans and all sorts of you know
manifestos and wonderful things
that i suppose it could get another
universal cut or
another consciousness of the universal
to buy into and they could both sit
together in the coffee shop and like
pour over them and be like
oh man this is so excellent but it
doesn't do anything
so it is just as hypocritical
he says the failure to act at all though
the necessity to act is involved
in the very talk of duty and here's how
he closes this
for duty without deeds is utterly
meaningless
moral obligation recognition of what one
ought to do
whether it be in relation to oneself in
relation to the other
in relation to society the the
environment even
moral duty without action
as he says is not just mere words it's
utterly
meaningless the words themselves
slowly lose their significance
you